we live in a very very unforgiving
society and you know some people talk
about things like snowflake array and so
on of the generation coming up and I I
think that it's slightly unfair unkind
if you live in a world where acting in
the world can come back at you at any
stage and you never ever have any
mechanisms to be forgiving you are going
to fear everything because everything is
so damn dangerous every word is undoable
is unendurable every action is undoable
and nobody wants to help you out nobody
and we all have a little bit of this you
know when somebody earns and strays or
does something terrible we are inclined
to forgive them if we already agree with
them if they are of our group or tribe
or if they are of our political view but
when it happens with our opponents we
destroy destroy and make sure they never
come back
that's why the trudeau thing is actually
quite a useful moment because I'm quite
encouraged by some of the response um of
the partisan response which is saying
don't let's do this but don't let's do
back to him what we know he would do to
us so it's true that if Donald Trump had
repeatedly you know I don't know how
many times but sometimes I just used to
put my feet up a Trump Tower and just
black up Melania I would just be there
on the tambourine yeah
I reckon he'd have trouble in the
Republican primary
I reckon that the left wouldn't let go
of that and so it's it's interesting
because this could be an opportunity to
try to pretend the Justin Trudeau is in
fact a racist white supremacist KKK hood
wearing maniac and bigoted and a lot of
Canadian politicians are doing that some
are doing it yeah the wiser ones will
realize that this is a very important
opportunity to show magnanimity and
victory to say you couldn't wanted you
Justin Trudeau wanted to make us play
these silly reductive political games
and you know God knows as a reason
enough to dislike the guy he you know I
mean I still think that at that moment a
few years ago and when a young woman in
the audience were first to mankind and
he said he the Prime Minister of Canada
says I think you'll find we refer to to
humankind these days that's simply first
of all no we don't but almost nobody
does and secondly so you're the Prime
Minister and you're using the platform
to sort of correct from some brow be
dead by then mansplain just asking a
question you know I mean though you have
some decent seats I'm just basic you
know I mean there's a power dynamic
that's gone wrong anyhow but it's such a
point whenever that guy gets this wrong
by turning out to have a bit of a thing
for doing blackface just can't believe
our luck
you know we could do the dishonest thing
to him that he would do or we could say
okay let's use this as an opportunity to
learn about how we could have a better
better thing going forward and I I give
this example with V with V in the
forgiveness chapter with V how do we how
do we how do we try to read other
people's words including the words of
people who we might disagree with in a
more honest light we've had this thing I
may have said to you before we've had
this strange thing in our society in
recent years writers comedians and
others used to operate on the basis that
we spoke and acted in a way that no
honest critic could honestly
misrepresent and then we entered at some
point in recent years is era in which we
had to try to speak and act in a way in
which you know in such a way that no
dishonest person couldn't dishonestly
misrepresent our actions and that can't
be done Holy's it can't be done without
driving yourself mad and so we need to
we need to work out how with our
opponents as well as our allies and
friends and so on actually behave in a
more reasonable manner
[Music]